this is not what they signed up for
isolating when they should be
socializing
at the third floor window of her block
we spoke to lucy who's tested positive
it's like a one in a lifetime experience
to go to uni
and ours is going to be different but we
are sort of trying to just make of it
what we can
and you had freshers week here just last
week how was that
i think people do get a bit more
sociable after a drink
but um i kind of don't blame them
but also like we were trying to be
careful as well
[Applause]
everyone in this flat is tested positive
too most though
are not showing significant symptoms i
have been
feeling quite ill a lot of us have been
feeling quite ill so i think
just kind of getting used to it and
looking after ourselves making sure
we're staying healthy
i think that's one of the really
important things looking after each
other as well we all know we've got each
other
the union that represents academic staff
here say the university
has just not listened to their concerns
the measures put in place
from our perspective don't go far enough
many more things could have been done
and we've been suggesting this
for months things like more
simple things like hand sanitizer in
classrooms the universities say they're
committed to enabling this generation to
learn
while also protecting everyone's health
and safety
they're putting it down to the amount of
testing that's going on here and the
university say
this shows their systems are working
they're expecting this surging cases
to be short-lived this is though the
biggest outbreak so far at a university
and even if it does move off campus it
won't leave this city
it's spreading and when it moves from
this age group
it finds people less able to fight it
off
tom parmenter sky news newcastle